foreign
[Music]
night a Toronto Festival turns violent
they hit them on the head several people
are sent to hospital when demonstrators
crash the party the politics believed to
be behind the attack
extreme weather turns a scout Jamboree
into a nightmare for thousands of teens
but it sounds like the problems with
this go Way Beyond the heat the
International Event that's put kids at
risk
practicality or politics it feels like
there's a lot more at play there the
Alberta Government faces backlash over a
decision to pause green energy projects
and out from the Shadows an Iranian
immigrant to Canada shows her true
colors
global national with Farah Nasser
reporting tonight Colleen Christie
good evening thanks for joining us
police from across Toronto converged on
a park in the city's West End trying to
put an end to violence at a community
festival today that injured several
people sending nine to hospital a large
contingent of officers was deployed to a
park on Toronto's west side where the
local Eritrean Community was hosting a
festival organizers say a group of up to
200 people showed up and began
disrupting the event tents were smashed
and set on fire and police say one
person was stabbed one witness believes
the others to be from Ethiopia's Tigre
region
Eritrea
they are not we are arrested they are
not from Ethiopia
Medics also treated patients at the
scene until last November Eritrea and
Ethiopia waged a two-year war against
the Region's ruling party in the Tigre
region during which more than 2 million
people were forced to flee their homes
there's finally labor Pace at the ports
on Canada's West Coast and now growing
calls to make sure such disruptions
don't happen again members of the
international Longshore Workers Union
voted almost 75 percent in favor of a
four-year deal that vote brings an end
to weeks of uncertainty at ports across
BC the association of Canadian
manufacturers and exporters says
disruptions that the ports cost an
estimated 500 million dollars in trade
each day they want the ports to be
declared critical infrastructure the
labor and transport Minister welcome the
news but said quote we don't want to be
back here again
much of BC remains under Smokey Skies
this weekend as wildfires continue to
burn right across the province these
images captured by the International
Space Station began with snow-capped
mountains that soon became blanketed by
smoke a special air quality statement is
in effect for much of the BC interior
with temperatures expected to stay above
average this weekend despite rain in the
forecast for early next week more heat
is expected through the month
South Korea is baking under intense heat
it's where thousands of teenagers from
more than 170 countries including Canada
have gathered for the 25th World Scout
Jamboree the 10-day education event was
supposed to be the trip of a lifetime
but for many extreme summer heat has
ruined their Adventure Jamie Maraca
explains why officials have chosen not
to cancel the event
this flat treeless landscape more than
250 kilometers outside of South Korea is
supposed to be a temporary home for more
than forty thousand participants at the
world Scout Jamboree
most are teens 14 to 17 but with little
access to shade or cooling during one of
the hottest Summers the country has seen
in years the 35 degree weather is taking
a toll oh that's bad
who cut absolutely dripping and sweat
the UK the largest contingent of more
than 4 000 Scouts moved its delegates to
a hotel after more than 100 participants
were hospitalized with heat related
illnesses during the opening ceremony
each stouting movement is an independent
organization and they have duty of care
for their children so they will decide
what is best for their children since
there have been more than 400 reports of
people falling sick including nine
Canadians a statement from Scouts Canada
says the 235 youth expressed a desire to
remain at the Jamboree given
infrastructure improvements and
participant feedback the contingent will
remain on site but delegates from the
U.S are opting to walk away
Kristen Sayers says her 17-year-old son
spent more than six thousand dollars
American to attend the Jamboree she is
now calling a nightmare but it sounds
like the problems with this go Way
Beyond the heat there's none of food
there's not enough water the South
Korean government is promising more
water trucks air-conditioned spaces and
Medics officials also rolled out tour
programs shuttling Scouts into Seoul and
other cities and have canceled the more
physically intensive events still they
have no plans of shutting down
regarding the operation plan of the
Jamboree the representatives of each
country held a meeting today and decided
to continue the event
but with a week left and more rain and
35 degree heat in the forecast Scouts
motto be prepared May mean for further
disappointment Jamie moroccer Global
News
[Music]
it's the middle of summer but a freak
storm in southern Germany has residents
seeing snow and hail a heavy hail storm
hit the city of root Lincoln east of
Munich on Friday it looked like winter
in some areas with Hailstone
accumulations of up to 30 centimeters
other areas saw heavy flooding
thunderstorms are forecast for the next
two days
a surprise announcement from the Alberta
Government this week is drawing
criticism from across the country the
province is pausing the development of
any new renewable energy projects for
the next six months the Alberta
Government says it's in response to
concerns from rural land owners but as
Heather your ex West explains critics
believe there are political motivations
at Play
with its wide open Sunny blue skies and
some of the gustiest Winds on the
continent Alberta has been an attractive
place for renewable energy investment
and up until recently the solar and wind
energy industry here was booming Alberta
certainly was leading the way we've seen
a massive expansion excellent wind and
solar resources from a kind of climate
perspective but also a great Market
structure it's why an announcement by
Alberta's government took so many by
surprise effective immediately and for
the next six months any approvals of
large renewable energy projects will be
put on pause we wanted to start
immediately on some significant issues
that we've we've heard that have been
raised by industry municipalities and
individual landowners the government
elected on the strength of its support
in rural Alberta was quickly praised for
the decision by rural leaders I must say
it's a bold and courageous step taking
high quality agricultural land out of
production and actually using as a solar
industrial renewable operation is that
the best use to land but clean energy
supporters are puzzled at best The
pembinet Institute estimates the pause
will put 91 projects worth 25 billion
dollars at risk a moratorium though
right as you have an absolutely booming
industry that doesn't make any sense and
I don't think that the desire to engage
people in a conversation warrants a
response that puts the entire piece at
risk it feels like there's a lot more at
play there particularly since there's
talk of
pollen gas development in the wake of
thousands of orphaned and abandoned
Wells with the provincial government
frequently at odds with Ottawa over
climate policy politics appear to have
played a role in blowing this decision
in Heather your ex-west Global News
Calgary
a day after Ukraine said it carried out
a drone attack on a Russian Navy ship
off Crimea there was another strike on a
tanker in the same region a Ukrainian
intelligence source for Reuters released
this video showing a drone sailing
toward the ship before impact the source
says it was transporting fuel for the
Russian military Russian officials say
the tanker was damaged but no one was
hurt
police in Pakistan have arrested former
prime minister Imran Khan after a court
sentenced him to three years in prison
he's been found guilty of illegally
selling State gifts during his tenure as
prime minister from 2018 to 2022 Khan's
party has condemned the ruling saying it
will challenge the decision in a
superior court since it's ousting from
power in a no-confidence vote in
Parliament in April of last year Khan
has been slapped with more than 150
legal cases
coming up a drying Trend how younger
Generations are moving away from alcohol
consumption
[Applause]
a chaotic scene in New York City Friday
after a PlayStation 5 giveaway caused a
mob scene the event was planned by
popular internet personality Kai sanat
but things got out of control and the
giveaway never happened massive crowds
gathered around Union Square throwing
supplies injuring officers and
destroying police cars police made at
least 65 arrests including sanat
well summer is prime patio season where
many enjoy cold beverages often of the
alcoholic variety but a new trend
suggests younger Generations have a
different idea of what constitutes a
good time taking alcohol out of the mix
in a story that aired on the new reality
Sophie Louie looks at the sober
curiosity movement
at a glance this looks like any other
night out
people are mingling
the DJ is bumping
the bartender is mixing
but there's one key thing missing
alcohol there's not a drop of it here
we like to create an atmosphere where
everybody is sober Elizabeth gascoigne
is the host of this booze free bar night
she came up with the idea a year ago
after deciding to go sober like many
people she found herself drinking too
much during the pandemic leaving her
with something she calls anxiety
anxiety in my experience is the feeling
that you get the next day after drinking
even if you're only drinking a glass or
two of wine just this residual anxiety
of what did I say the night before what
did I do did I embarrass myself it's a
question her generation is posing a
recent study found they drink 20 percent
less than Millennials who in turn are
drinking less than gen xers and Baby
Boomers and it's not necessarily because
they have addiction issues they're just
curious
sober curious
gen Z I think they're realizing that
like maybe the consequences of alcohol
are not actually worth the mental health
effects
here in Canada the sober curiosity
movement is definitely brewing beer and
wine sales are at an all-time low except
when it comes to non-alcoholic products
and at the drive canteen in Vancouver
they can attest to that this pale ale
like you could pour it blind and people
wouldn't know that it's a de-alkalized
product it's so good
owner Doug Steven has carefully curated
his convenience store with a focus on
fun
candy and snacks jerseys and sneakers
and their top seller beer Wine and
Spirits without the booze
as long as it's delicious that's the
biggest thing for us we just keep seeing
more and more people coming through who
want to kind of shift how they view
alcohol
[Applause]
[Music]
it's clear there is a thirst for
something different
that thirst this should be more on the
dry of the spectrum
EO of sansorium a BC based Online
Marketplace for alcohol-free beverages
tonight she's giving people a taste of
what's out there
the big takeaway I hope people get from
tonight is really an expanded definition
about sobriety you could have a mindful
relationship to alcohol that lets you
have a drink once in a while or you
realize that you don't like it at all
and you decide to leave it without
having this Rock Bottom story and this
sober curious are eager to sample I
think there's something about getting
something that tastes like an adult
beverage that's what I loved about it
Sophie Louis Global News Vancouver
I had incredible Discovery the massive
a quan Manitoba
[Applause]
Mississauga's Malcolm Spence gives
Canada the win at the 2023 helinca
Gretzky cup Canada defeated host team
czechia 3-2 in overtime to win the World
under 18 tournament it's the 24th time
Canada has taken home gold
foreign
[Applause]
kind of win in Regina competitive eater
Joey Chestnut set a new record eating
304 mini Donuts in eight minutes uh the
Queen City exhibition the event raised
seventy two thousand dollars for the
local food bank the wind is no big
surprise Chestnut has won New York's hot
dog eating contest 16 times
researchers in Manitoba have made an
exciting Discovery they have found what
appears to be a complete fossilized
skeleton of a mosasaur the so-called
T-Rex of the deep joining us is Adolfo
kutara who is the executive director of
the Canadian fossil discovery center in
Morton Manitoba thanks for joining us
thank you for having me well this must
be a huge thrill how did you find these
fossils
well this is the result of the last few
years the of improvements are doing in
the center and and it was found by Jerry
Peters this is our field technician he
was scratching cleaning the surface in
our property in this monitor was coming
with a new excavator that we acquired
last year he's very knowledgeable and
and just he felt that he has his
craziness were faced that there was
something there just one Bond or one
fossil just showing up from the surface
and just stopped immediately the tractor
and started to dig with hand tools and
and just he realized at the time that it
was not just an insulated bomb it was
just showing up one very well then
another version another vertebra and now
leaving we are starting to find teeth
and skull elements so it's very exciting
to to be able to to find this this
muscle so do
deplete
suddenly we talk always a complete the
skeleton we when we find 70 75 80
percent of the skeleton it's almost
impossible to find 100 there's always
some element missing right so right now
we are about the half of the skeleton
and we are pretty sure that this is
going to be very very complete now most
of us are familiar with the fossil Rich
Drumheller Alberta but you have your own
very special window back in time right
there in southern Manitoba tell us about
that this used to be a seabed
exactly so uh 83 million years ago there
were a Interiors away like a Channel of
ocean communicating the Gulf of Mexico
with the Arctic Arctic Ocean and the
Hassan Bay so at that time Manitoba was
completely under this interior warm
swallow sea Andrew Helen Alberta they
were in the west coast of this interior
Seaway so that's why they find dinosaurs
because they were animal land animals
and we only find marine animals what
else might you find buried underneath
the Earth
well uh we have Bruce this is the
biggest Mosasaur skeleton in display in
the world and next year this is by
chance uh we we will acquired a piece of
land that is the continuation
of where Bruce was found in the 70s so
we have high expectations about that
portion of land because all the animals
all the specimens we found there are
huge and uh so we have really big
expectations about what we can find this
year and next year
executive director of the Canadian
fossil discovery center in modern
Manitoba thank you
thank you
next an Iranian immigrant to Canada
defies fear for pride
[Music]
North America's biggest Caribbean
Carnival has returned to Toronto
thousands came out for the 56th annual
Grand parade Saturday decked and
colorful and sparkly and even feathered
costumes it's a summer Staple in the
city celebrating Caribbean culture and
history that also attracts millions of
visitors from right around the world
it's Pride weekend in Vancouver and the
celebration has special meaning for one
resident she fled her home in Iran
fearing she might be killed for who she
is and now that she's in Canada she's
determined to share her Iranian Pride
negri explains
foreign
is not a secret anymore
the pride flag and her native flag of
Iran United a moment Unthinkable for the
transgendered woman
[Music]
it's so important people see we are here
we are leaving we are Iranian lgbtq
behind the cheers and celebrations a
darker truth I had a lot of problem in
Iran as a trans woman Harris meant and
discrimination
but you can't go to police and you can't
tell to police because it's your fault
because
you are different Shia had gender
affirmation surgery in 2012 and feared
for her life in Iran now she's seeking
refuge in Vancouver Iran was answered
for me and is unsafe for the people's
like me
in September two Iranian women sentenced
to death Amnesty International says it
was due to their perceived sexual
orientation and gender identity and
defending lgbtq plus writes on social
media the United Nations is demanding
their release homosexuality is
punishable by death in Iran our Sean
Parsi is a queer activist exiled for
love the only disagreement between
clergies is the method of killing some
believe that they have to be stoned to
that some believe that they have to be
hanged and some believe that they have
to be cut in half by a sword he's an
Iranian gay man living in Canada I
decided to do something in order to stop
these kind of inhuman and barbaric
actions arsham founded the international
railroad for queer refugees and the
marathon Foundation helping the queer
community of the Middle East these are
the pictures the rainbow kids in Iran
sent to us China is now doing her part
to help people back home with Iran's
Rainbow Children turning to her on
social media for support they hold the
rainbow flag or transgender flag at the
street in Iran we are trying for Freedom
here in Iran too
I think they are so brave bravery on the
front lines of a battle for basic human
rights negarmo shahedi Global News
and that is global national for this
Saturday night I'm Colleen Christie
tonight's your Canada is two fawns
taking a break from the Sun in Maple
Ridge BC thanks for watching hope you'll
join us again tomorrow have a great
night
[Music]